- Excellent! Excellent!
- François Legault sait
un terrain sensible.
FRANÇFRANÇOIS LEGAULT, chef,
Coalition avenir Québec
- Il y a des personnes qui privt
comme si on parlait du diable.
- Qu'à cela ne tienne,
il veut créer des centres
médicaux privés,, en quelque
sorte, où la population pourrait
obtenir des rendez-vous
médicaux, des chirurgies
d'un jour et se fa urgences min.
Le but : désengorger le réseau
public.
CHRISTIAN DUBÉ, candidat,
CAQ, La - Si on - Si on - Si onr
le plus possible les P3, P4, P5
qui viennent à l'urgence et qui
ne devraient pas être là,
l'achalandage dans nos urgences.
C'est énorme, ça!- D'ici 2025, t
que deux centres privés voient
le jour : un à Québec,
l'autre dans l'est de Montréal.
À terune dizaine dans la provin.
ÉRIC DUHAIME, chef, Parti
conservateur du Québec
- Le mot en "P" n'est plus tabou
depuis que le Parti conservateur
en a parlé hier en conférenc
de presse.
- Hormis pour Éric Duhaime,
au privé, l'idée passe mal
chez les adversairAQ.
DOMINIQUE ANGLADE,
cheffe, Parti libéral du Québec
le privé en santé, c'est
pour accélérer les chirurgie ch.
GABRIEL NADEAU-DUBOIS,
co-p.-parole, Québec solidaire
est tombé en amour avec le privé
et dans ce cas-là,
l'amour le rend aveugle.
PAUL ST-PIERRE PLAMONDON,
chef, Parti québécois
dégradation programmée
des services publi
- Mais pour certains citoyens,
le débat public / privé importe
peu. Ils veulent d
- J'aime mieux faire le public
en premii on est mal
pris, je trouve que c'est
une bonne chose.
- Moi, jqui nécessite de plus en
plus de soins. Et les retards,
is, dans le secteur
public sont très difficiles,
humainement très difficiles.
ces minices minices minices mint
de meilleures conditionsde travt
assure qu'il n'y aura pas
d'exode du personnel.ouvertes 2,
et les GFM, de 8 à 8, sept jours
sur sept, donc pas différent de
ce qu'on a dans le public,
puis la qualité des soins va
(applaudissements)
- Même si les centres serantrest
gérés et construits grâce a des
fonds privés, François Legault
promet uerts par
la Régie de l'assurance maladie.
yens n'auryens n'auryens n'aurys
à les payer de leur propre
poche.
Ici Alexandre Duv
Radio-Canada, Côteau-du-La